conseiller universel non mais ça
n'existe pas ce poste les présidents ont
tous types de conseiller elles ont même
des tonnes de conseiller il y en a pour
l'économie pour la diplomatie pour la
sécurité etc chaque domaine de
compétence à son ou ses conseillers donc
c'est impossible d'être conseillée
surtout à la fois et bien si en fait
après sa victoire aux élections
présidentielles de 1981 françois
mitterrand donne à jacques attali le
bureau à côté du sien à l'elysée et
contrairement à tous les autres
conseillers le jeune jacques attali un
énarque et polytechnicien de 38 ans a le
droit de suivre tous les sujets il est
le conseiller universel du nouveau
président
[Musique]
qui est jacques attali pour faire simple
c'est un haut fonctionnaire très
influent dans la vie politique française
depuis la présidence de mitterrand dont
il était le conseiller comme je viens de
vous le dire en plus d'en être l'ami
personnel cette influence fait
d'ailleurs de lui une personnalité
controversée comme il a été proche de
tous les présidents à l'exception de
jacques chirac on imagine qu'il est un
homme de l'ombre qui tire les ficelles
dans les coulisses mais quoi qu'on pense
de son influence dans la vie politique
française il faut reconnaître qu'il a
une culture générale exceptionnelle
il est capable de parler avec profondeur
et dans le détail d'à peu près tous les
sujets ses amis et les personnes qui le
fréquentent disent qu'il est
véritablement l'homme qui sait tout
dans les réunions internationales
lorsqu'ils conseiller mitterrand les
conseillers des autres présidents
étaient saisis par la supériorité
intellectuelle de jacques attali alors
qu'eux mêmes étaient déjà des hommes
très brillant comment at il fait pour
avoir une telle culture générale c'est
un don c'est de la triche ou bien il a
simplement énormément travaillé je vais
vous révéler les trois secrets de la
culture générale de jacques attali et
puis pour chaque secret je vous dirai
comment vous pouvez vous aussi
l'appliquer concrètement alors petite
précision je ne peux pas vous dire des
choses évidentes du style c'était un
très bon élève il a fait de grandes
écoles où ils ne passaient pas séjourner
sur netflix non je vais vous révéler des
choses que vous ignorez et que j'ai
découverte mois dans ce livre le cas
attali du journaliste guy sitbon c'est
un livre qui à presque 30 ans mais vous
pouvez le trouver d'occasion sur
internet donc regarder attentivement
cette vidéo jusqu'au bout et vous allez
découvrir des choses étonnantes sur
jacques attali mais surtout vous allez
pouvoir vous approprier des méthodes
originales pour développer votre culture
générale a bien plus efficacement
fin des années 50 jacques attali et son
frère jumeau bernard attali sont tous
les deux élève au prestigieux lycée
janson de sailly dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris il habite
d'ailleurs dans la rue du lycée rue de
la pompe en bas de leur appartement il y
à une librairie et bien café simon
attali le père des deux jumeaux il leur
a ouvert un compte dans cette librairie
c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent venir
prendre les livres qui les intéressent
sans payer et lui le père réglera la
note plus tard en clair c'est comme un
buffet à volonté toute leur enfance les
jumeaux attali ont été encouragés par
leur père à avoir une consommation de
livres absolument débridée par exemple
pour leur bar mitzvah la bar mitzvah
c'est la cérémonie par laquelle les
juifs célèbrent l'accession à la
majorité religieuse du garçon à l'âge de
13 ans donc les jumeaux attali ont 13
ans pour leur bar mitzvah ils reçoivent
en cadeau la bibliothèque entière de la
pléiade alors votre réaction c'est
peut-être de vous dire qu'il faut avoir
les moyens parce qu'un livre de la
pléiade et il y en a pour entre 50 et
100 euros donc pour la bibliothèque
entière l'addition est salée bien sûr
c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas ça qui est
le plus important ce qui est révélateur
dans ce cas d'autres c'est que les
exemplaires de la pléiade ne sont pas
n'importe quel livre non ce sont des
livres sacrés à deux égards d'abord ce
sont des objets de luxe avec une reliure
en cuir plein pot et dorée à l'or et
puis ce sont aussi des livres sacrés
parce que la collection de la pléiade
publie uniquement les oeuvres majeures
de la littérature au sens large la
collection donne la priorité à la
littérature française mais il ya aussi
de la littérature étrangère pour un
auteur être publiés dans la pléiade
c'est une consécration parce que ça veut
dire que son oeuvre fait partie du
patrimoine littéraire de l'humanité et
donc en offrant la pléiade entière à ses
fils de 13 ans c'est surtout un rapport
au savoir que le père des jumeaux attali
leur transmet et ce rapport relève
presque de la religion un livre est un
objet sacré ce que contient cet objet
sacré le savoir le savoir a donc quelque
chose de divin il faut respecter il faut
révéré le savoir un peu comme il faut
rêver rire une divinité le premier
secret de la culture générale de jacques
attali c'est donc qu'ils accordent une
grande valeur au savoir le savoir c'est
presque une religion pour lui et ce
rapport au savoir que lui a transmis son
père n'a jamais quitté jacques attali il
avait toujours un livre avec lui et il
c'est énormément parce qu'ils étaient
intimement persuadé que le savoir est
sacrée et c'est certain que si vous avez
un tel rapport au savoir si c'est pour
vous une religion non pas simplement un
aspect de votre vie mais une dimension
essentielle crucial qui vous accompagne
au quotidien qui détermine votre manière
de voir le monde votre rapport à
l'existence bref si le savoir a dans
votre vie la place qu'aurait une
religion et bien vous allez développer
une culture générale sans commune mesure
par rapport à l'homme ordinaire l'homme
ordinaire qui voit lui dans un livre un
simple objet un assemblage de feuilles
bon c'est bien beau de révérer le savoir
mais comment faire en pratique pour
développer ce rapport au savoir rapport
au savoir c'est vrai que ça fait déjà
pas très concret mais vous pouvez quand
même faire certaines choses ça commence
par l'état d'esprit abandonné le rapport
au savoir de ceux qui pensent que les
livres ne servent à rien que les idées
c'est du vent de la masturbation
intellectuelle
bien sûr la masturbation intellectuelle
ça existe mais ça ne veut pas dire que
réfléchir que résonnaient manipuler des
idées c'est forcément 20 au contraire si
vous le faites bien vous avez le pouvoir
de changer le monde les livres dirigent
le monde disait voltaire et 15 dira
encore plus précisément les idées
façonnent le cours de l'histoire soyez
en persuader et vous vous cultiverez
bien plus facilement voilà pour l'état
d'esprit et maintenant quoi faire
concrètement pour mettre à profit ce
premier secret intéressez-vous davantage
aux livres je veux dire les objets
matériels flâner dans les librairies
prenez les livres qui attire votre
attention et regarder les compulser les
examiner la couverture analysé le
sommaire etc ou bien faites comme moi
qui ne vit pas à proximité d'une
librairie française passer du temps
chaque jour à découvrir de nouveaux
livres grâce au moteur de recherche
d'amazon apprécié la couverture regardez
les notes lisez les commentaires voire
même des extraits et puis si votre
bourse le permet autorisez vous à
acheter des livres de manière compulsive
moi j'en achète un à deux par jour comme
ça comme les idées sont la matière
première de mon travail c'est moins
d'entreprises qui paye tout est donc
j'ai un budget livres entre guillemets
il limité comme jadis les jumeaux attali
dans leur librairie de quartier
80 livres jacques attali a écrit plus de
80 livres alors qu'il a 60 18 ans à
l'heure où je fais cette vidéo inutile
d'avoir fait polytechnique comme lui
pour se rendre compte que ça fait plus
d'un livre publié par an et c'est
certainement plus d'un livre par an
puisqu'il avait 29 ans lorsque le tout
premier est paru si jacques attali était
écrivain à plein temps il aurait bien pu
écrire ses livres lui même comme il le
prétend seulement au vu de toutes les
autres activités qu'il a exercé en même
temps vu sa vie mondaine il a
certainement recours à des [ __ ] moi
j'écris mes livres
parce que vous voulez les revoir mais il
n'est pas le premier ni le dernier mais
ce n'est pas le sujet ce qui est
révélateur à l'égard de sa culture
générale c'est la diversité des sujets
de ses livres comme il est économiste de
formation il écrit des essais
d'économies mais l'économie est déjà
mêlé à de la science politique jacques
attali sort déjà de son domaine de
compétence académique il a également
écrit des ouvrages d'histoire comme une
histoire des usages et des conceptions
du temps plutôt le genre de livre qu'on
imagine composé par un historien
professionnels il a aussi écrit un
dictionnaire amoureux du judaïsme ce qui
nécessite des connaissances théologiques
et historique il a écrit une théorie de
la musique dans son essai bruit je les
lui c'est intéressant il a encore écrit
des livres qui relève de la philosophie
ou du développement personnel si on veut
bon je ne fais pas une liste détaillée
de tous les thèmes sinon vous allez
partie puis la vidéo sera mal référencés
je veux quand même ajouter que jacques
attali a encore écrit des romans des
mémoires est aussi j'y reviendrai à
propos du dernier secret des biographies
j'en ai lu plusieurs et je les trouve
réussi bref la meilleure manière de
qualifier le travail littéraire de
jacques attali c'est de dire qu'il est
écrivain tout simplement écrivains comme
il est docteur en économie on
s'attendait à ce qu'ils écrivent des
essais d'économies comme la plupart des
docteur en économie mais non jacques
attali écrit sur surtout ce qui
l'intéresse en fait le deuxième secret
de sa culture générale c'est qu'ils
ignorent les frontières du savoir une
idée est une idée d'où qu'elles viennent
peu importe d'où elle vient l'importance
et est elle intéressante me permettent
elles de mieux comprendre le monde
éventuellement de le changer c'est grâce
à ce secret que la culture de jacques
attali et si général comme la plupart
des professionnels du savoir se trouve
dans le monde académique et que ce monde
dit le champ du savoir en différant
souche han han différentes spécialités
par exemple l'économie l'histoire la
littérature etc eh bien nous avons
tendance à avoir un rapport académique
au savoir concrètement nous avons
tendance à voir des spécialités qui
serait le monopole des spécialistes
l'économie aux économistes l'histoire
aux historiens la sociologie aux
sociologues etc et bien sûr les
spécialistes sont rassurés que nous
pensions comme ça car cela préserve leur
monopole mais les frontières entre les
domaines du savoir sont artificiels non
seulement ces frontières sont bien
souvent floues mais elles ne
correspondent à rien dans la réalité ce
sont des illusions autorisez vous donc à
devenir ce que jacques attali appelle un
esprit universel vous n'avez pas besoin
d'avoir un master en économie pour
creuser la question de la dette d'être
prof de français pour critiquer le style
de proust d'être passé par la fac de
philo pour vous essayez de lire du
nietzsche et j'ai même envie de dire
vous n'avez pas besoin d'être médecin
pour prendre en main votre santé le
savoir est un seul et unique espace où
vous êtes libre de vous déplacer comment
appliquer ce secret et bien c'est simple
noeud bord n'est pas votre curiosité à
une seule ou à quelques disciplines
intellectuelles ne vous dit pas par
exemple à cette année c'est d'économies
je n'ai pas fait d'économies donc ce
n'est pas pour moi alors ça ne veut pas
dire que ça ne va pas être difficile
parfois mais vous devez partir du
principe qu aucun champ du savoir ne
vous est ferme et réfléchie c'est
uniquement en termes d'idées et de fait
et posez vous une seule question cela
m'intéresse style cela peut-il m'aider à
mieux comprendre le monde ça c'est
plutôt pour l'état d'esprit mais quoi
faire concrètement vous avez intérêt à
privilégier dans vos lectures et plus
généralement dans votre consommation de
contenus les disciplines intellectuelles
les plus généralistes c'est à dire
celles qui requièrent le moins de
connaissances techniques la discipline
idéale de ce point de vue c'est
l'histoire après vous vous endormirez
probablement en lisant des historiens
professionnels qui nous a souvent le
lecteur dans les détails donc vous avez
plutôt intérêt à lire des vulgarisateurs
qui eux savent stimuler l'intérêt du
lecteur et se concentrer sur l'essentiel
encore plus précisément pour vous
émanciper des frontières artificielles
entre les disciplines intellectuelles
vous avez intérêt à lire de grandes
synthèses générales sur l'histoire de
l'humanité le jean est assez en vogue
depuis les années 2000 le modèle du
genre et bien sûr sapiens de yuval noah
harari
je veux être le raymond aron de la
gauche c'est ce que se disait jacques
attali à la vingtaine son ambition
c'était donc de devenir la référence le
penseur de référence de son camp
politique comme raymond aron le
philosophe libéral l'avait été pour la
droite au xxème siècle mère et moi on
n'est pas le seul grand intellectuel qui
a inspiré jacques attali il y avait
également marx qui étaient comme lui un
esprit du monde c'est d'ailleurs le sous
titre de la biographie qui lui a
consacré marx qui était donc comme lui
extrêmement curieux qui ignoraient les
frontières intellectuelle au point que
son chef-d'oeuvre le capital le livre le
plus influent du 20e siècle est un
mélange au moins d'économie de
philosophie de sociologie et d'histoire
et marx intervient encore dans d'autres
champs du savoir marx c'est d'ailleurs
le penseur auquel le père de jacques
attali simon attali ne cesse de le
comparer il comparait son fils un marx
avec fierté mais aussi avec regret il me
fait le coup de marx tout le monde va le
haïr et il mourra dans la misère en
économie enfin c'est joseph schumpeter
le théoricien de référence de
l'innovation qui inspire jacques attali
le troisième secret de sa culture
générale c'est donc d'avoir des modèles
si vous aimez bien certains
intellectuels qu'il vous inspire que
vous admirez leur culture générale bien
cela va vous donner envie de les imiter
et de développer votre culture générale
pour leur ressembler de la même manière
qu'un jeune footballeur trouve la
motivation pour s'entraîner et ainsi
améliorer son niveau dans sa volonté
d'imiter son ou ses joueurs préférés
vous trouverez vous la motivation et
l'élan pour développer votre culture
générale dont le désir de ressembler à
votre ou à vos intellectuelle préféré il
n'y a rien d'anormal là dedans car le
désir humain est éminemment mimétique
comme le dit aristote imiter et dans la
nature même de l'homme nous fonctionnons
comme cela mais comment mettre à profit
cette propriété de la nature humaine
pour développer votre culture générale
comment faire concrètement voici ce que
je vous recommande faites de votre
intellectuelle préféré ou éventuellement
de veau aux intellectuels préféré faites
en des maîtres ou des mentors si vous
voulez lisez tout ce qu'ils écrivent
écoutez toutes leurs interventions
regardait toutes leurs vidéos intéressez
vous à tous les sujets qu'ils traitent à
tous les livres qu'ils mentionnent à
toutes les références qu'ils évoquent
nourrissez-vous de l'heure id et servez
vous en pour développer votre culture
générale et ainsi améliorer votre
compréhension du monde vous vous
lasserez probablement un jour de ces
modèles vous mettrez à penser que vous
les avez survalorisé mais entre temps
vous aurez bien développer votre culture
générale moi par exemple j'ai eu ma
période nassim taleb il y a quatre cinq
ans j'ai lu tous ses livres écouter ses
conférences je le suivais sur twitter
etc aujourd'hui je suis passé à autre
chose mais j'ai découvert grâce à nassim
taleb beaucoup d'idées originales qui
ont changé ma vision du monde comme
celle de la vie est négative à du cygne
noir ou de lentilles fragilité j'ai
aussi découvert dans ses livres des
personnages et des anecdotes tirées de
l'antiquité très intéressant
en synthèse les trois secrets de la
culture générale de jacques attali ce
sont de sacraliser le savoir d'ignorer
les frontières du savoir et de
s'inspirer de modèles qui ont une grande
culture générale si vous mettez en
pratique ses secrets vous vous
cultiverez bien plus rapidement voilà
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu et puisqu'elle vous sera utile si
c'est le cas donnez lui un pouce bleus
et puis laisser un commentaire pour
améliorer le référencement de la vidéo
ce n'est pas grand chose et ça m'aide
vraiment vous étiez sur 1000 et de
culture générale rappelez vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui j'ai une question à vous poser vous
croyez vraiment que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont il parle bien sûr que
non sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
grand chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
[Musique]
et
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'ya pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivés les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
renan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussit à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils les appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations
c'est dans les débats et ils ont le
recul nécessaire pour faire preuve
d'esprit critique ça vous intéresse et
bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets et
je vous explique comment les appliquer
dès aujourd'hui pour vous cultivez 10
fois plus rapidement sans vous prendre
la tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant roux à droite de la vidéo
souhaitant qu'ils ont sur celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo
croyez moi faites le et vous me
remercierez